April 18 1775 a new world I just closer
to revolution Walter Cronkite and a team
of CBS news correspondents told the
events of this day April 18th in a
Bicentennial special CBS News
correspondent David Kahane has been
covering American activities inside
Boston and is on the scene now all
things are as they were them except you
that was more than a hundred years after
this story of Paul Revere first gained
widespread fame in 1860 Henry Wadsworth
Longfellow plucked Revere story from
relative obscurity for a poem his goal
was to remind northerners and
southerners of their shared
revolutionary past attempting to avert a
civil war at the time it was an
existential plea listen my children and
you shall hear of the midnight ride of
Paul Revere but it's been repeated
countless times after in slightly less
serious settings one of my land two if
by sea three shirts Lord Allah if you
bring them to me from cartoons movies
even the three stooges
[Music]
young fellows retelling while inspiring
was also a bit inaccurate how do the
Redcoats go Paul and where there's your
answer Congress I see the famous
lanterns were a signal to the Patriots
not to revere and he was actually one of
three riders that night the men over
there are talking to Paul Revere the
silversmith who is also a leading figure
in the American Liberty movement Revere
who joined the cause after his metal
business began to suffer based on
British policies first traveled by boat
that famous night then by horse from
Charlestown Massachusetts to Lexington
as the rebellion waited for word CBS
news correspondent Mike Wallace arrived
at the home of the Reverend Jonas Clarke
in Lexington Massachusetts are there any
new developments Mike not yet Walter so
far the British have not arrived but
neither is any messenger also along the
way Revere did not say the British are
coming as has been repeated in other
tellings but the regulars are coming
Revere was eventually detained his horse
confiscated but his ride worked the
Patriots rose up and the first shot of
the revolution was fired the next day
Paul Revere a man who wanted nothing
more than to work with pewter and silver
and help start a revolution how cool is
that in Michelle I have to thank our
incredible producing team for unearthing
that dandy from the CBS archives
dandy is right those archives are sub
Bessel